on va savoir un petit peu plus qui vous
êtes on va vous faire un hard et viau
vous pensez à quoi alors en ce moment là
je pense vraiment sincèrement je suis en
train de me demander si j'ai eu raison
de venir dans cette émission je pense
que oui pour l'instant quand vous vous
regardez le matin la glace vous dites
quoi
je n'aime pas me regarder le matin dans
la glace je déteste mon image je déteste
me regarder à la télé je déteste me
regarder sur un écran c'est non non je
n'aime pas du tout ça mais croit qu'il
ya beaucoup de gens qui font de la télé
qui sont comme ça quand vous étiez petit
vous auriez aimé ressembler à qui à bout
pourquoi moi parce que je regardais déjà
la télé quand avez vous pleuré pour la
dernière fois je pleure très souvent oui
alors là ça moi c'est vraiment de vendre
un film devant un film bien foutu ou
changeriez quoi en vous si vous aviez
une baguette magique à part votre pub
donc oui vous dire de plus négatif sur
vous je pense que j'ai pas de talent
voilà je pense que je suis un gros
bosseur mais je pense que j'ai aucun
talent vous n'avez pas de dons mais du
talent oui parce que quand on réussit
c'est quand même du talent vous feriez
quoi s'il ne vous restait que 24 heures
à vivre
l'amour pendant 24 heures un vide
fermement pendant 24 heures bah oui
pourquoi pas autant essayer c'est avec
du viagra avec plusieurs personnes alors
qu'allez vous fait jean marc morandini
que nous ne sachions pas c'est pas tout
ce qui est ma vie privée vous ne la
connaissez pas et je pense que c'est
mieux comme ça
une bonne oeuvre une bonne action oui
mais ça se dit pas ça en fait ben moi
j'aime pas les gens qui vont à la télé
pour raconter leurs bonnes oeuvres
moi j'en fais mais je les garde pour moi
une mauvaise action plein à acheter des
chaussures
nathan
session en bas